so on this program i try to strike the
right balance between being complacent
and being alarmist
i try to avoid being either i try to
just be realistic and kind of give it to
you straight
simply telling you that there is concern
among democrats about minnesota
i think is accurate i don't think it's
alarmist and i don't think it's
complacent
donald trump according to some
democratic strategists
could win the state of minnesota and you
might be worried
you might be wondering minnesota or
should we really be worried about that
why
well the truth is that minnesota hasn't
voted for a republican presidential
candidate
since 1972 that's just shy of 50 years
ago
and if you look at the polling it sort
of looks okay right i mean it looks okay
for joe biden
joe biden's currently leading the
polling in minnesota by an average of
3.7
but the problem is that 3.7
really isn't that much to be comfortable
with minnesota
was actually already almost a problem
for hillary clinton in 2016 hillary
clinton did win minnesota in 2016
but only by about 1.5 and if you look
further into history barack obama won
minnesota by 11.
uh in 2008 he won it by eight in 2012.
john kerry won minnesota by four in 2004
al gore won it only by two in the year
2000 and so when you see it this close
and you know that there's voter
suppression that's not in the polling
there's meddling that's not in the
polling there's all sorts of things
that are not reflected by the polling i
am not particularly comfortable
with joe biden being up by only 3.7 in
the state of minnesota
now there's another reason that
minnesota could be a problem
and minnesota could turn into the
wisconsin of 2020. remember
in 2016 hillary clinton was widely
criticized for not
spending time in wisconsin a state that
she ultimately lost by a very small
margin
and it was one of those three states
that flipped the results
to donald trump electorally joe biden
may have a similar situation
right now and what i mean by that is in
florida
joe biden is struggling with latino
voters right now in florida
and it seems as though joe biden is
going to have to devote
even more resources to florida florida
always a focal point particularly for
democrats because
taking florida away from the republican
candidate is so powerful
in these electoral races to 270 but
again
if joe biden has to put more time and
effort into florida than he would
otherwise have to ordinarily have to
were it not for the hispanic vote
he may not have the resources or time in
minnesota
and minnesota is exactly the type of
state that the polling could get wrong
remember
the 2016 polling was mostly correct
at the national level at the national
level the polling said hillary's up
three
and she won by more than two in the
popular vote but it is also true
that the polling was not correct in
wisconsin in wisconsin
hillary clinton in the polling was
winning by
six and a half and you might recall as i
just mentioned five minutes ago
donald trump won wisconsin by about
three quarters of a point the wisconsin
polling was very very wrong
so what do we do about minnesota about
all of these
situations well we learn from the past
we learn from past experiences
we understand that democrats are worried
about minnesota and so we should be
worried about minnesota and we should
focus on it
when trump advisors what let me back up
when trump publicly says all our polls
look great we're winning everything
it's bs we all know it's bs when
privately trump advisers and republican
strategists say we're not writing off
michigan
we understand that michigan could get
complicated when
privately they start looking again at a
state like minnesota
we understand that we can't ignore it we
never
stop the focus on getting out the vote
and
any one of these states could be the
difference maker now in the coming weeks
i'm going to show you some of my
plausible
electoral maps now why the hell would
you listen to me about that you
you really shouldn't i got it way wrong
in uh in 2016.
in 2016 i believed the wisconsin polling
and so on my map i had wisconsin
definitely for hillary i was wrong
uh but i am going to give you some
scenarios
and incredibly there is a scenario for
for this upcoming election that would
put the electoral votes
at 269 to 269. it's not
the most likely scenario but it's also
not that unlikely
and it depends on maine being split uh
as they do
uh in terms of their electoral votes so
we will get to that
we have plenty of time for that